welcome to the live stream gonna be the
last live stream for a little while
sadly I think we can say sadly
although people are telling me sad
people happy people that maybe it's not
the worst thing in the world not or no
uh oh boy I've got another geez I gotta
close this out had a whole second live
stream going on don't want to do that
that's gonna slow down my computer so
this is gonna be the last live stream
for a while and tomorrow's broadcast
program is going to be the last one for
a while as well because we are going on
vacation we're not going off the air
it's not because of the YouTube ad
pocalypse that we're not doing any more
shows or anything like that
it's time for David Pakman show summer
vacation vacation of course very
important a lot of people in the u.s.
don't take vacation and it's important
for the staff and everybody and me to
get a break it's also important for the
audience to get a break from us I am
confident that there will be
alternatives while we're gone or
something so I have a bunch of stuff I'm
going to talk about I'll tell you about
what's gonna be going on during the
vacation I'll tell you about a couple
other things that are going on how to
follow my trip what I'll be doing we
tried Soylent on the program today and
that relates to what producer Pat is
going to be doing there's some pretty
clever people that have been making
patreon contributions that I want to
talk about and dispel some myths about
as well so a lot to talk about the super
chat is on so all normal livestream
parameters are in play protocol one I
think is what we could call it which is
basically it's just a normal live stream
it's really live unless you're watching
a replay I will answer your questions I
will read your comments and react to
them super chat is the best place for
that it's the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window I've been making an
effort also to sort of get through a
sampling of the regular chat as well the
non super chat although it's tough
because it moves so quickly a lot of it
is subtle trolling in other words
trolling that's not quite bad enough to
get you blocked but not the type of
stuff that I'd be fine
myself responding to on a regular basis
either right new members and patrons who
sign up during the stream will get live
shoutouts and thank you so I've got some
interesting announcements related to
patreon and membership as well and
please know Oh obvious trolling in hate
it's just boring it's not fun and it's
not funny and the moderators in the chat
have been empowered to use their
discretion based on the general
guidelines that I've put in place to
block and time people out okay now as
far as patreon goes this is the last
sort of patreon telethon we're gonna
have for a while although I will address
in a moment what could happen that would
make me do a livestream during the
vacation I think you might find the list
quite interesting and compelling in a
number of ways we're targeting 19:30
patrons today okay one nine-30 that's
only 15 additional patrons and if we do
that we will only be 70 patrons short of
the 2,000 patron goal as you can see
there in this screenshot taken just
minutes ago when we reach 2,000 patrons
something a very serious thing will
happen which is I'll do an entire
broadcast show from the studio with my
hair like this all of the YouTube clips
that day I will have this appearance all
of the broadcast radio well radio you're
just listening I guess I feel like
you'll be able to tell from the audio
that my hair is like this but of course
on our TV show as well so we are
targeting 2,000 patrons and we are
pretty damn close tonight's target is
1930 and I will address the growing
scandal over over the Louis Motamedi and
'not on pack 'men patrons that have
become increasingly visible at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will talk about that a little bit later
okay so let's talk about the vacation we
are going on vacation it's important to
go on vacation and really the concern is
that the news cycle moves so quickly
right now that even during the weekends
a whole bunch of crazy stuff happens and
we're sort of playing catch-up on Monday
here we're actually taking a proper
vacation
until closer to the end of August so
anything could happen and that brings me
to what would be an occurrence that
would get me to livestream and interrupt
my vacation because I will have my
microphone with me as I typically do
I'll be using my I will not be using my
HD webcam I will be using my built-in
webcam if necessary but I think the
following would justify a livestream
definitively number one if we go to war
with North Korea there will absolutely
be a live stream if that happens if
there is any kind of indictment related
to Robert Moeller's Trump Russia
investigation doesn't matter who it is
but I think that that would definitely
warrant a live stream regardless of
where I am or what the situation is and
whether I will have a good internet
connection or not remains to be seen
because I will be visiting family in
Argentina have planned this several many
months ago and have not been in
Argentina visiting my family in my birth
country for years so it is a much
overdue trip and a lot of interesting
things I believe are going to be
happening on that trip and if something
crazy happens on my trip maybe I will
live stream but as far as politics go
right now the hottest things that are
going on I would say our possible
escalation with North Korea possible
progress with the Trump Russia
investigation maybe an indictment who
knows what else and also the possibility
of another firing right I mean I think
if Jeff Sessions gets fired it's kind of
on the back burner right now if I don't
know pick whoever you want if someone
else gets fired I think that that would
also warrant a live stream but also you
don't know I I think the real big
breaking news would be the unpredictable
stuff and thus what could I really say
it would be it's it's not predictable
what it is that might cause me to have
to livestream because it could be so
absolutely major now Pat producer Pat
has also announced and we're going to
delve into this in more detail on
tomorrow's program on tomorrow's bonus
show actually but he is going to be
taking a cross-country road trip the
August 21st solar eclipse is going to be
part of it so
think that that is going to be an
interesting factor as well for producer
Pat but he has revealed that he will be
bringing with him supplies of Soylent
drink which is a four hundred calorie
drink that is high and who knows what
all sorts of stuff and you know it's got
protein and micronutrients macro
nutrients who knows what it has anyway
we tried Soylent on the program today
and so today's bonus program Members
Only bonus show is huge for a number of
reasons number one you actually get to
see intern Bryan's face intern brian has
been working all summer diligently on
writing articles related to the show
that get published in all sorts of
different platforms including Huffington
Post he has been working on long form
deep dive investigative pieces that you
will see during our break because we've
got a whole bunch of content planned for
during the break but you have not seen
him so now on the bonus show today brian
actually makes an appearance and he
participates in the trying of Soylent
and as a preview I didn't love it okay
I'm not gonna say more than that but the
first thing I would do if I were not
currently a david pakman show member and
I decided to sign up like right now in
order to get a live thank you and access
to the bonus show and all the other
great stuff I would immediately go to
the August 10th bonus show and check out
it's right at the top of the bonus show
we try silent drink the three of us in
studio and if you want a 40% discount
off of your membership you can use the
coupon code
I voted seventeen I am going to do
something that I've never done before
and may never do again which is I've
established today's patron target is
1930 that means we need just fifteen new
patrons during the livestream and we
will hit our goal I will create and
release a 60% discount code I've always
sort of goofed around between 50 and 59
percent when we hit our patron targets
if we hit 1930 patrons during today's
stream because again
this is the last chance for a while
because we are going on vacation after
tomorrow's program I will create and
announce to you and to you only a 60%
discount code and that will get you all
the member benefits including getting
access to today's bonus show where we
try silent for people in the chat saying
it has no flavor that is not true just
because it doesn't have a flavor that
you like or that I liked doesn't mean
that it has no flavor so we will discuss
all of those things on today's bonus
show which you get access to if you sign
up as a member okay what will be
happening on the YouTube channel during
the upcoming David Pakman show vacation
any number of things we have for long
form pieces the schedule for those
pieces is monday and thursday over the
next two weeks so over the next two
weeks in the late afternoon Eastern Time
on Monday and Thursday we will be
releasing one or releasing each of our
four long-form investigative pieces one
is on the myth of the violent left one
debunks the false notion that socialism
has never worked not a socialist but i
am interested in facts and thus we
debunk the myth that socialism has never
worked one is on the nonexistent voter
fraud and real problem of voter
suppression and then fourth and actually
this is the one that's going to be
published on Monday the first one of the
long form pieces it is on classical
liberalism and the new fad of people
saying they are classical liberals
and it's called classical liberalism is
pretty effing conservative because
that's sort of the truth classical
liberalism is very conservative and we
will be releasing those for deep dives
for you during the vacation and we've
got about thirty other stories thirty
other videos of all kinds that we will
also be releasing for you during the
vacation so you may almost not even
notice that we're gone if you were on
YouTube because we've got you know close
to 35 or 36 different stories in total
that we'll be releasing for you so very
very exciting things we take the
vacation seriously because it's
important to have vacation but we also
would not want to just go
on YouTube okay we talked about Soylent
on the bonus show let me talk about well
let me jump into the super chat first
and then I've got a few other things
that I'm gonna want to talk about super
chat is the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window Ryan Couture has sent a
five dollar super chat saying what was
your reaction to Anthony Weiner pleading
guilty you're talking about back in May
right Anthony Weiner guilty I believe
that was months ago Anthony Weiner
pleads guilty to federal obscenity
charge let me remind myself of exactly
what he pled to plug guilty to a felony
crying openly as he admitted to conduct
he knew was as morally wrong as it was
unlawful the plea agreement ended a
federal investigation into a series of
sexually explicit pictures and messages
that Weiner sent to a 15 year old girl
in California it cost him his marriage
his estranged wife humi Abbadon filed
for divorce etc etc I engaged in obscene
communications with this teenager I mean
it wasn't surprising what had happened
it wasn't surprising when it happened
because this is a guy who has been doing
this stuff for a long time and there was
really little doubt that he had done it
with this individual either and she was
15 years old and that's it so I was not
hugely surprised it didn't seem like
there was really any other way out of it
or around it unless I missed some other
guilty plea from Anthony Weiner but I
don't think that I did a rich ropa thak
or pay thak has sent a $2.00 super chat
do you need a burl Flynt friend very
very appreciative of your concern a
retro but no I have one and one is sort
of the post that I'm able to handle so I
think I think I'm in pretty good shape
as far as that goes
I be berserk has sent the $5 super Chad
do you think that the Dems will take the
House and Senate in 2018 there's sort of
two answers to this right I mean one
answer would be just to talk about polls
and what the polls
showing and this is the percentage or
that's the percentage probability that
the Dems take the Senate I I want to
talk about it from a more strategic and
broad point of view which is if the
Democrats want to take the House and
Senate in 2018 there's sort of three
major tips that I can provide number one
stop talking about who elite Democratic
donors are donating to for 2020 in fact
stop donating to camallo Harris or
whoever for 2020 and start putting that
money into 2018 races that's number one
number two do not run as Republican Lite
and we talked about this in my interview
that aired yesterday and today on the
broadcast show with Charles Darbar
running as Republican Lite is not has
not been a good strategy for Democrats
it sort of started as Charles durbur
talked about in sort of modern era with
Bill Clinton in some ways and it's just
not a good strategy particularly now and
number three talk about Trump Russia
followed Trump Russia push for a full
investigation on Trump Russia but have a
platform that stands completely alone
from Trump Russia and that it doesn't
depend on Trump Russia being a thing and
won't be destroyed if Trump Russia goes
away I've talked about single-payer
health care I think it would be great to
run on we are against corporate crony
corruption C cubed as they could call it
for lack of a better term and we are
going to be very very aggressive in
making sure that people who committed
financial crimes are held accountable I
think there's a number of ways to go
about it but I think it will depend on
that I think it's gonna be an uphill
battle probably in both probably
probably in both okay let me make an
effort now to jump into non super chat
questions because I think it is only
fair I am NOT here only to answer
questions from people who can pay okay
Jose Aguilar says why do Argentinians
hate Mexicans I don't know any
Argentinians that hate Mexicans I'm more
into Argentinean and I find the Mexican
people to be some of the nicest most
genuine and hospitable people that I've
met
I really look forward to getting back to
Mexico and hopefully I will before the
end of this Kent this calendar year I
I'll ask around during my trip to
Argentina Jose but I I'm not aware of
Argentinians hating Mexicans let's see
what else we've got
in the non-super chat vacations are
necessary to maintain sanity I agree
what else do we have here people talking
about we are fake news am i going to be
playing golf not gonna be playing any
golf it's actually winter in Argentina
and save for the very north of the
country which you know flipped from the
US where it gets warmer as you go south
in Argentina being south of the Equator
it gets warmer as you go north save for
the Northwest region of the country it's
it's not super warm I mean it's 60 in
the capital city of Buenos itis and I'm
gonna be in Mendoza a little bit and
it's roughly the same temperature there
I think I should look before I pack and
lastly flick wants to know whether Pat
had to sleep with me to get on the
program no no he didn't and and Pat and
I both exclusively date women actually
so that unlikely unlikely to to be
something that happens okay let me jump
into a few thank-yous here we are trying
to get to 1930 patrons by the end of
today we have already set a major record
this month in that we have never before
been above the 1850 patron mark and we
are now over the 1900 patron mark just
ten days into August we are at nineteen
fifteen and now we are at nineteen
sixteen because Roy Scott has just made
a $2 a month pledge the deal is as
follows we're trying to get to 2,000
patrons and when we do I believe it's
when not if I'll do an entire broadcast
show with my hair like this completely
out of control people seem to love it
kids seem to be scared it's the stuff of
nightmares but that's okay because it's
all to raise money to recover from the
YouTube ad boycott which has led to an
85 percent reduction in our ad revenue
but that's the longer-term goal 2,000
patrons tonight's goal is 1930
and if and when that happens and I hope
it's a matter of when rather than if
when we get to 1930 patrons tonight I
will create and release for you the
biggest membership coupon code we will
have ever done period it will be a 60%
coupon code I am doing this only because
it's the last livestream before the
vacation and we want to go out with a
bang
but we've got to get to 1930 patrons
first and along the lines of those
memberships I want to say thanks to
Christopher Ravello Raven Fuchs Robert
boo Leo and Michelle Feeney all of whom
have signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership they now get instant access
instant access to the bonus show and as
I mentioned earlier in the show on
today's bonus show we do a show every
day for our members a producer Pat
intern outgoing intern Brian and myself
tried Soylent drink 400 calorie drink
because it is something that producer
vegan producer Pat will be bringing with
him on his upcoming cross-country road
trip which he will be doing on our
vacation so don't don't miss it it's
absolutely fascinating the the trying of
the Soylent Green Ryan Couture has sent
a $2.00 super chat how hard should a
president work vacation time I have no
problem conceptually with presidents
taking vacation I do believe that it's
particularly hypocritical for Donald
Trump to be taking not only the amount
of vacation that he's taking but also
the expensive vacations that he's taking
especially when he promised that he
wasn't going to especially when he
promised a Barack Obama for golfing
Obama was golfing a lot less and on the
cheap
golfing overwhelmingly at government or
military I don't know what they're
called golf courses Donald Trump on the
other hand traveling all over the place
on target to spend in his first year in
office as much as President Obama spent
in all eight years in office so I don't
have a problem with presidents taking
vacation I think that Trump is a total
hypocrite and he's also not getting
anything done it might be good to get
something done before you go on vacation
Rashaad has sent a $2 super chat thank
you very much appreciate that purple
chime has sent a $5 super chat have you
heard from Timothy Snyder Trump declared
using emergency powers for opioid
addiction didn't explain how he'll use
powers yeah I am very interested in
interviewing Timothy Snyder we have
reached out to him by Twitter
we have also I also saw a bunch of our
viewers we're reaching out to him by
Twitter I have not heard anything back
he may just not be interested in doing
the show which is sad because you know
our audience does buy books when we
interview people who have written books
and there are books that are relevant to
modern politics and our audience is
interested they do buy books so it's sad
to me particularly for me because I want
to talk to Timothy Snyder I think his
new book is fascinating but it's also I
think it's a bummer for the audience
Isaiah Rho would you ever want to learn
a third language and what are your dream
travel destinations in the future you
know my French is pretty good my French
is conversational and if people speak
slowly like I'll sometimes watch French
news and I can pick up a lot of it if
they speak slowly a lot of times they
don't so I think if I were really to
focus on a third language French would
be the one it is really similar to
Spanish in a lot of ways I also often on
have worked on learning Hebrew and it is
just difficult I mean it's you know a
totally different alphabet of course and
that makes it significantly more
difficult than an Italian which
basically I mean if when I speak to
someone who speaks Italian I can speak
Spanish they can speak Italian we
understand about 85% of what we're
talking about so yes I mean I think
French or Hebrew would be the ones I
should focus on if I were to really
pursue that further dream travel
destinations I'm very interested in
visiting Japan it is very far and it is
not particularly inexpensive to get to
and once you get there so I I don't know
exactly when I would get there I've
never been to any of the Scandinavian
countries so that's interesting to me
and there's a lot a lot of places on my
list I'd like to do more travel
South America I'd be very interested in
visiting Peru for example I've never
been to Colombia my South American
visits are always you go to one aside us
and you visit family so I've not had
time to really explore anything else and
on this trip though I will be going to
the Mendoza region of Argentina which
should be should be great in Eze sorne
has sent a five British pound super chat
David thanks for your insights and
intelligent analyses apropos what is
your view of the recent twenty million
dollar finance bonanza for the Young
Turks yeah this is interesting a lot of
people have been asking me about this I
don't mean listen once you get twenty
million dollars from Jeffrey Katzenberg
it's harder to make the case that you
are independent media in the same sense
that the Young Turks once were now more
than likely if genk is smart and I know
junk is smart I know genk I've known
jank for nine years at this point
actually if junk is smart he and the
whole team over at TYT including steve-o
and everybody else I would presume that
he they would have negotiated that none
of these investors have any kind of
editorial control and you know we did a
small round of investment when we moved
to Boston from New York and there was
never even a discussion about our
investors having editorial say nobody's
ever tried to I mean it's just very very
cut and dry but we're not talking about
twenty million dollars so once you have
20 million plus they had eight and a
half other million million I believe in
in raised money once you're talking that
type of money you can still be
independent but are you still grass
roots I don't know it's like what do all
these different different terms mean but
I think it my interest will be in seeing
you know the Young Turks I think is up
to about 70 or 80 employees at this
point when you go from 80 to 300
employees there are really significant
things that start to change within the
corporate culture unavoidably right like
no matter what efforts you make when you
have 300 staff all of a sudden that
everybody knows everybody and even with
80 depending on how thin
organized not everybody knows everybody
so the dynamic is going to change pretty
significantly and I'm interested to see
what happens and what the future holds
there BW 85 has sent the twenty dollar
super chat post vacation would you
consider inviting Brett Weinstein on the
show I'm sure you both agree on most
political issues but I think he could
provide interesting insight into the
current university environment yeah
Brett Weinstein's this professor from
Evergreen State now I'm confused between
Evergreen State and the Bowling Green
massacre but I believe it's Evergreen
State College or university you know we
tried to get him on the show he actually
did get back to me via Twitter direct
message and said he was thinking of
going on how do I envision the interview
going I sort of gave him a sense I want
to talk to you about your experience etc
etc and he never got back to us so I
presume that he is not interested in
being on the program
Maria Romero has sent a $5 super Chad
have a great vacation thank you very
much any ghost has sent a $20 super chat
I sent a $20 super jet hey bud I love
the David Pakman show
but I find there's a lot of overlap and
content with secular talk The Young
Turks NPR CNN etc I've loved your
long-form stuff like your gender pay gap
deep dive and I'd love to see more
content like that Thanks well do I have
good news for you and he goes during our
upcoming vacation we will be releasing
for roughly 25-minute deep dives let me
see how long these actually are I think
they're roughly 25 minutes and these are
really good these are going to be I
think something that a lot of people
would like where are they here okay the
four deep dives that we will be
releasing on Monday and Thursday of the
next two weeks classical liberalism is
pretty effing conservative that's a
close to 20 minute
piece the myth of the violent left 20
minute piece on that debunked socialism
has never worked 20 minute piece there
and voter fraud isn't a problem voter
suppression is over 23 minute piece
there so those are really good and you
know I hate to say this but we've been
talking about you know the YouTube ad
boycott were down 85 percent in terms of
YouTube revenue from point
one earlier in the year 2.4 currently
there have been multiple articles
written about how the david pakman show
YouTube channel is absolutely getting
crushed one in The New York Times the
New York Times wrote about how we're
getting crushed on YouTube Wired wrote
about how we're getting crushed on
YouTube sadly if we're not able to make
up the funding gap the deep dives would
sort of be the first thing to go because
they're they're like the extra thing
we've got our daily production schedule
and our guests and our interviews and
and the live calls and all of this stuff
all of these sorts of things to sound
like Arnold Schwarzenegger and then in
addition to that we've got the deep
dives that we work on which are a whole
other thing the narration is recorded
research is done by the production team
and editing and it's a lot of work so
sadly those would be the first things to
go if something had to go of course my
goal is that nothing go my goal is that
nothing go whatsoever and on that note
I've got a few more new members to thank
I want to thank Tim Nellis Tim Nellis
has just signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership ray frost is a new
newly minted david pakman show member
Sean Monteith has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and jared
tyrell jared Terrell thank you so much
for signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership not only do you get instant
access to all the great member benefits
your supporting the show and the work
that we do and because you get access to
the bonus show you can check out today's
bonus show the August 10th bonus show
and we tried Soylent calorie drink I
don't even know what to call it meal
replacement show Ryan Couture has sent a
$2.00 super chat how could you win a
debate with Ben Shapiro strategy I don't
know that's a really that's a really
general question how could I win I mean
I think it would depend on what the
subject matter is and being prepared
right I mean I'm not I don't know how
else how else to say it I would I would
prepare and I would try to win I would
try to win the debate but there is
currently no debate scheduled with
Shapiro so I don't know we've emailed a
couple times over the last year and I
don't know that he's hugely interested
in being back on the show he was on a
few years ago we talked about guns I
don't know that he's it really
interested in being back on TIF ruby has
sent a $2 super chat with no question or
comment thank you very much I appreciate
that let me talk about a couple of the
other things that I wanted to mention
okay oh yeah so some people have noticed
that there have been patrons under the
names Louis Motamedi of course former
David Pakman show producer Louis
Motamedi and gnihton Pakman former TV
director and a little brother gnat on
Pakman and I have no reason whatsoever
to believe that these are the real Louis
Motamedi
and 'not on Pakman I spoke to Louis
yesterday about a wedding for both going
to in a couple of months and he didn't
mention it and I think he would have
mentioned that he was a patron if he had
donated and also the person who's using
the name Louis Motamedi on patreon is
asking for me to do segments in Spanish
and Lewis basically doesn't know a word
of Spanish so I don't know why he would
do that once he thought it was funny
which I don't think he would and then my
brother my brother innit on Pakman that
user was also asking for something else
on patreon I don't remember what it is
now yeah I don't know but anyway I don't
think either of those people are
actually the individuals they claim to
be and I mean we've actually seen people
during our IndieGoGo campaigns we've
gotten donations from kim jeong-hoon
Dennis Rodman I mean I don't know listen
I don't care what name you contribute
under if you're contributing that's
really sort of the thing that matters
but no I have no reason whatsoever to
think that the real Louis Motamedi
nor NAT on Pakman are making any
contributions on patreon all right TIFF
Ruby has sent a $2 super chat does
producer Pat have a girlfriend now that
would not be an appropriate
a question for me to answer that would
not be an appropriate question for me to
answer in this format maybe in in a
closed hearing I think that maybe that's
something that I could deal with but I
don't think that that would be fair to
deal with right here Richard Oh has sent
a to British pound super chat The Young
Turks staying independent would you come
to the UK okay I think these are two
separate questions it's a statement The
Young Turks is staying independent all
right and would I go to the UK I was
just in the UK in December I was there
in the week leading up to the new year
and I was mostly and done of London a
little bit in the outskirts great time
absolutely fantastic time cuisine was
not so good
other than the Indian food which was
absolutely tremendous best Indian food
I've had I would say but I did not get
to see too much of the countryside the
British countryside although I would
have loved to Tim Nellis Timmy Nellis
has sent the $5 super Chad I've noticed
Marx is getting more popular among
progressives what are your thoughts on
communism well I am NOT a communist I'm
not an advocate of communism I we are
going to be releasing a 20-minute deep
dive long-form piece into debunking the
false notion that socialism has never
worked people usually point like to the
to the USSR or Cuba and they say hey
socialism has never worked and it won't
work and of course that represents a
pretty fundamental misunderstanding of
history and we are gonna be doing an
really great video on that but I I am
NOT a communist I consider myself in
favor of social democracy so well
regulated capitalism that puts a heavy
influence on social programs and sort of
the Scandinavian model that that's my
approach and yeah I don't know what else
I can really add to that Ryan Couture
Ryan Couture has sent a $2 super chat
saying prediction what is the what will
the outcome of North Korea be you know I
still maintain that someone is going to
talk sense into Donald Trump and explain
that what what is he really going to do
in North Korea preemptively I do not
believe that Kim jong-un is actually
going to be a sort of like the first
mover the first striker if there is
going to be a military escalation with
North Korea although I certainly could
be wrong I've been wrong in the past but
my sense is that a lot of this North
Korea stuff is bluster from Trump in
total desperation to take attention away
from the daily failings and failures is
fake yeah failings his award anyway the
daily failures of his administration as
well as the Russia scandal we just
learned that Paul Manafort s-- house was
raided on July 26 Donald Trump took to
Twitter hours later wondering why Jeff
Sessions hadn't fired the deputy
director of the FBI
you know III think that this is seen as
an opportunity for Trump to look strong
and take attention away from these other
issues that are going on so I genuinely
and I'm hopeful that it is not going to
escalate and you know I read some
interesting op-ed pieces that actually
say even if you're against nuclear
proliferation what about trying to come
to some agreement with Kim jong-un where
they can you know do some more research
and sort of okay some additional
research into this development of
nuclear but make it very clear that they
can't threaten people they can't use it
and it's very hard to take the moral
high ground when we have not really been
a leader in terms of the anti
proliferation movement when it comes to
nuclear so it's an interesting it's an
alternative approach for sure but I
think that this is mostly a distraction
from Donald Trump and I would would not
at all be shocked if he tries to keep it
going for as long as possible but Rex
Tillerson is already so
trying to cool off the problems that
Donald Trump has created let me do a
couple more thank yous here for people
who have signed up for membership while
we've been talking membership of course
the number one funding source for the
program gazette denton gazette Denton
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership day Abraham day Abraham is a
new member at david pakman.com slash
membership getting instant access to all
the great member benefits john bowling
john bowling is a member now at david
pakman.com slash membership and chris
fourtner as well a lot of new members
signing up but you know what we have
this 40 percent discount code available
if you want a sixty percent discount
code just help us get to nineteen
hundred and thirty patreon donors if we
can get to 1930 patrons then i will
create and release a 60 percent
membership discount code we are only
fourteen patrons away it's slow tonight
but I'm hoping we can get there I do
need your help in order to do it if we
get to 1930 patrons which would be a new
high watermark for us I will create and
release a fantastic sixty percent
discount code for you okay let me dig
into the non super chat a little bit
because there are a lot of questions
happening there and I want to get to
some of those why is the show going away
we're going on summer vacation vacation
very very important a few people asking
if I am now clean-shaven and indeed I am
you know I rarely actually do a full
shave with shaving cream because it's
just why bother I use a buzzer but when
I go on vacation I try not to bring any
shaving supplies with me
and in order to do that I will start
fresh with a totally clean shave so you
you have you are absolutely correct
I am indeed clean-shaven a couple people
getting blocked and banned and messages
deleted glad to see that the moderators
are active there when is producer Pat
getting his own show does producer Pat
even want his own show that would be a
question for producer Pat
okay let's jump back into the super chat
as there are a number of them coming in
here Qiu Zi has sent a $10 super chat
hey David this North Korean news has me
worried that this is the straw that
broke the camel's back leading to World
War three do you think it is likely that
attacking North Korea or vice versa will
lead to World War three I don't think so
because North Korea doesn't really have
that many allies so aside from whether
it would achieve anything strategically
to attack North Korea whether it could
backfire
how many civilian deaths it would cause
which seems to be completely unconcerned
until Donald Trump Donald Trump seems
totally unconcerned with that there
aren't that many allies that would come
to the defense of North Korea it's like
China is the closest thing to an ally
that North Korea has Russia will
sometimes due to its proximity there are
some North Korean I don't even know what
the right word is camps or something but
I don't want to misspeak in in Russia
and rural Russia so I don't think it
would lead to World War three it could
be a disaster anyway but I don't believe
it will work a lead to World War three
Evon Holloway has sent a $2 super chat
Mesa or poram right so I guess it's
which Jewish holiday do I prefer I don't
do anything for poor him for Pesach
which is Passover if I'm around
I will go to like a very non-religious
casual Passover Seder and it's mostly
sort of for the social aspects that I do
it so I think I would I think I would I
would say definitely Pesach wins with me
Lawrence Fogle has sent a $5 super chat
is it problematic that the democrats are
not-- are now both officially the party
of the rich and a big business also
aren't 3/4 of presidential assassins
democrats i have no idea the party
affiliation of presidential assassins i
think that we might have the problem of
small sample size when it comes to that
to really make any general assessments
is it problematic that the democrats are
officially the party of the rich and of
big business or and a big business
listen
there are endless criticisms of the
Democratic Party I don't know what you
mean that they are officially the party
of the rich I've not seen that I've not
seen that data I don't know exactly what
you mean but if you want to send that to
me line I would be glad to respond at
some future point D Knight has sent a
five-dollar super chat mana for traded
yet Mike Flynn is missing in action has
Flynn turned state's evidence I was
thinking of that I was thinking of that
because we haven't heard from Mike Flynn
we were under the understanding that
there was a second grand jury looking
into Mike Flynn related stuff so I don't
know where he is and I think it's a very
fair question
hey do people want this guy Jose Aguilar
banned in the chat I'm seeing him really
just going off with endless comments and
talking about you know liquid bowel
movements and just a lot of really weird
stuff and I think at one point he was
talking about am races just on and on
and on I don't know if that's someone
that should be banned or not he's asking
if messages are being deleted maybe
maybe they are Jose because we do have
moderators observing what's going on but
I don't know if I'm even noticing that
Jose Aguilar is constantly sending
messages then there might be a problem
but but listen let's I'm leaving it up
to the moderators to decide what to do
about Jose Aguilar their TIFF Ruby has
sent a $2 super chat with no question or
comment thank you I appreciate it
xx Jamaica has sent a $2 super chat what
are your thoughts on the deaths besito
song which of course means slowly
translated from Spanish I like the song
it's interesting it's gotten three
billion views on YouTube which i think
is a record it's an interesting song
because I believe it isn't it the first
spanish-language song to do this well on
the like non Latin music chart or
something like that I don't know I've
got no problem with the song although
I'm not into Justin Bieber's
participation in the remix not into that
I
guess I'm not a belieber a five-dollar
message was sent and then retracted I
don't even know who sent it because it
was retracted Jeana Chase has sent a
five dollar super chat thank you very
much Jeana I appreciate that and on that
note let's get caught up with members
and patron thank-yous Lauren has made a
$2.00 per month pledge things are slow
tonight with patreon we started with
1915 patrons and I said let's get to
1930 and I will set up a 24-hour 60%
membership discount code and we've only
gotten two new patrons so far which gets
us to 19 17 13 to go I hope that this
isn't like an embarrassing fail I would
love it I mean we we only need something
like three or four percent of the people
in the watching a live stream right now
to do a a $1 contribution and we will
get to 1930 and then everybody wins
because we will have a 60% discount code
but hey listen if people don't want it
we don't have to do it but I would love
it I would love it also a few new
members a lot a new member signing up
today Carol earn Berg and Stephen James
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code
I voted 17 I've voted 17 will save you
40% but if we get to 1930 patrons then
you will be able to save 60% no good
have sent a to Canadian dollar super
chat thoughts on the Google memo that
the guy was fired for you know I did a
whole video about this earlier in the
week and some people are furious with me
saying that my opinion is wrong and
clearly I didn't read the memo I did
read the memo and that I'm sort of
taking an on a non position by saying
that there was no infringement on free
speech because Google is not the
government and I mean I'm just getting
endless criticisms for it but then I
also did get some pretty thoughtful
thank-yous and praise for that from
people saying hey you know what you I
appreciate that you weren't
apoplectic aliy on one side or the other
because it's actually a more complicated
issue than than some are making it out
to be some some are saying this guy was
fired because he had the wrong opinions
and bla bla bla bla bla and this is the
language policing speech speech policing
he's not allowed to be a conservative
and work at Google or whatever and then
there's others who are saying that
there's absolutely nothing concerning
here whatsoever because the guy is
totally out of line by saying that we
should explore whether there is some
genetic basis for men being predisposed
to engineering and women not and I've
said many times I don't think there's
anything wrong with exploring that why
wouldn't we want to know that I would be
against discrimination on that basis a
lot of these questions about men versus
women have been looked at and we found
that there is no practical difference
why one can do the particular job better
than others but I have no problem
whatsoever with looking into that and
I'm not into suppressing investigation
into that and so so I think that it is
more complex than some people make it
out to be princess Nucor has asked with
a $2 super chat what is your favorite
Argentinian food very very good question
well so as you may know Argentinean food
is heavily it primarily Italian and also
French influenced because of Italian and
also French immigration to Argentina so
for example like one of my favorite
items is milanesa which is basically
like a breaded chicken or beef cutlet
thin fried typically and you usually get
it with french fries and it's absolutely
fantastic and I look forward to in just
a few days when I visit Argentina
sampling also the pastries are fantastic
in Argentina croissants are are
excellent I may be biased I believe
Argentina has the best croissant
croissants in the world a lot of other
pastries are great empanadas in
Argentina are great there's different
styles depending on the region so in
some regions of Argentina
I believe that I don't know which region
it is it would be common to put
hard-boiled egg and/or black olives in
your empanadas in addition to whatever
the standard stuff is you know meat
chicken whatever also many of many
vegetarian options in other parts and
now I don't know if this is in Argentina
or maybe in another country but I think
there's a region of Argentina that does
raisins inside the empanada sort of a
sweet and savory thing which is pretty
good yeah so anyway those are those are
a few things look forward to sampling
the cuisine
oh and by the way a lot of places with
the empanadas a lot of places deep fry
empanadas and you can get fried
empanadas in Argentina but the big thing
in Argentina is that they are oven baked
number one way fewer calories and and
way less unhealthy for you but also I
like it better I like the oven baked
empanada way better than the fried
empanadas in fact I may not continue
getting fried empanadas at restaurants
under protest
Herbert Holmes has sent the ten dollar
super chat is there a word for the act
of or rather a person who looks at the
dominos as they lie with no regard for
the antecedent events and their effects
on the status quo yeah that's a good
point like you look at like you look at
North Korea and ignore what got us to
where we are with North Korea and just
focus on do we bomb North Korea or not I
don't know what the word is for that I
mean I think it's called historical
ignorant I don't know if there's like a
more concise way to sort of sum that up
but I think it's its historical
ignorance TIFF ruby has sent another $2
super chat with no question or comment
thanks very much I appreciate that
xx Jamaica has sent a $5 super chat
please guys become a patreon the David
Pakman show is the best show on internet
Bigley
yeah listen I agree I agree and at least
one person clearly is heeding your
advice double X because kinky machine I
assume that's not a real name but
someone who goes by kinky machine on
patreon has just pledged two bucks a
month that gets us to 1,900
and 18 patrons we are targeting 1930
today we are targeting 1930 and we
started at 1915 we are 12 away help me
get there I don't I don't want to be
cooked by the audience I know I'm not
really using that correctly but it just
is hilarious I want to make it I don't
want to fall short especially because
this is our last livestream until after
the vacation unless major news break so
I don't want to end on such a sour note
not hitting the patreon target and I
think 1930 is very very reasonable Wow a
lot of super chats continuing to come in
here Jacob Ball has sent a $5 super chat
did you see that poll that 52% of
Republicans are okay with postponing the
2020 2020 election if Donald Trump wants
to what are your thoughts on that yeah
we're talking that's our lead story on
tomorrow's program we didn't get to it
today remember under Obama when you had
these the early alt writers and the Tea
Party are saying Obama is going to
destroy the Constitution and appoint
himself president indefinitely by
suspending the election and of course
there was no evidence he was going to do
that and he didn't he relinquished
control of the executive branch of the
government on time
exactly when he was supposed to now
Republicans have been pulled and asked
it's a really good good poll actually
because it asked a lot of interesting
questions including do you do you think
Trump won the popular vote and a lot of
Republicans do if Trump says in order to
preserve the integrity of the election
to prevent voter fraud that we have to
delay the 2020 election would you be
okay with that and more than half of
Republicans say that they would be it's
stunning and we are going to be talking
about that on tomorrow's program
Kristina sent a $2 super chat what did
you or will you have for dinner tonight
I'm gonna have two bottles of chocolate
Soylent drink just because I love the
Soylent we tried on the bonus show today
so much
no actually today I've got kind of kind
of convenient because I leave on
vacation tomorrow now
this week I had a blue apron which of
course is a sponsor of the program full
disclosure but I had a blue apron three
dinners from blue apron and today is the
last one which is some kind of eggplant
thing some kind of eggplant thing I
don't remember exactly David Moss has
sent a $2.00 super Chad did you watch
the Ben Shapiro and Genki euchre debate
yeah I've been asked about this a couple
times this week
I watched 10 or 15 minutes of it I
watched about seven and a half minutes
of Ben and seven and a half minutes of
jank roughly and I was not they both
came very well-prepared I did not think
anybody destroyed anybody else you know
we talked about this on the program or
on the livestream not that long ago both
of them knew what the subject matter was
going to be they could both end to sit
there both experienced enough to
anticipate what sort of rebuttals or
retorts they might hear from the other
so there was nothing particularly
surprising about it okay Jared Hoyt has
sent a twenty dollar super chow
are you concerned about a potential new
financial crisis looming 18 to 24 months
given that American household debt has
hit 12 point 73 trillion UK and au debt
is climbing and the Trump administration
is completely disinterested in
regulating Wall Street's yeah so I am
concerned about this and I've been
talking about this off and on for a
little while we are starting to see not
that everybody is exposed to stock
market risk because not everybody owns
stocks but the stock market is becoming
as you've been following if you've been
following Trump's Twitter account very
very overvalued so if you look there and
you look at what's happening in the
housing market and you look at what's
happening with the dollar value the
dollar the value of the dollar index
which tracks the the relative value of
the dollar compared to other currencies
has been crashing since Donald Trump's
election and yes I am absolutely worried
about a new financial crisis it is going
to be difficult for a lot of people
because if you're in your early 30s or
maybe now maybe more like if you're in
your late 20s I would say is a better
example
you have only been in the labor market
presuming you sort of went right into
working after high school or went to
college and then straight into working
you have never really experienced a
significant downturn in the economy
because you started working when the
recovery began in the early years of
President Barack Obama so I think that
it is going to be new territory for many
many people and many of the new people
that are in the workforce and I you know
beyond that economic predictions are
yeah I don't I don't know that anybody
is really that great at making that
economic predictions but eventually
there will be a downturn and we're
certainly four years closer to it than
we were four years ago so absolutely
that is a concern sure at Jared Jerrod
I'm not sure how to pronounce it any
ghost has sent the $20 super cheque
David love you and this isn't an attack
but when it comes to your objective take
that Muslims perpetrate most terrorism
do you factor in that the we bomb women
children and hospitals daily that we
bomb women children hospitals daily and
call it collateral damage yet listen
this is a fair question in terms of what
is the line between terrorism and
foreign policy and military actions it's
a fair question no I am NOT factoring
that in because I'm talking about a very
particular type of terror is that fair
maybe not and I'm open I'm open to
considering that I mean it's a totally
fair challenge and criticism any ghosts
but no I am NOT factoring that in when I
say that Athena Harding sent a ten
dollar super chat when Trump made his
fire and fury comment I don't know if
you noticed but he looked extremely weak
and scared with his posture arms crossed
and sinking in his chair I did notice
that the body language was weird I also
it's sort of disappointing that Melania
and Kellyanne Conway who were sitting on
opposite sides of Trump I think Tom
Price was between Trump and Kellyanne
Conway and Melania Trump was right next
to trump the camera was zooming in
so we didn't see their reactions when he
made that comment and I really would
have loved to have seen that because
that that would have been fascinating I
am very worried we are not going to
reach our patreon target of 1930 because
I've only got about five or ten minutes
that I can stay because I've got a lot
to do before we go on vacation a lot of
work to do still to sort of wrap up so
we were hoping for 1930 we're at 1918 I
don't know if we will get there we
continue to have new members come in
we've got Daniel McMahon who is a new
member as well as Palo mongrel thanks to
both of you for signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership it's still
possible we are only 12 patrons away and
if just twelve of you throw in a dollar
a month in the next five or ten minutes
we will make our target and the target
will be really great because it will
allow me to create a 60% discount code
for membership and then you'll be able
to get memberships at a 60% discount so
it's a win win win win win for everybody
involved and I strongly encourage you to
make that patreon contribution 1930 is
the target it's getting down to the wire
it would be sad it would be very
low-energy if on the last live stream
before the vacation we don't make it
Kerry Burnett has sent a five-dollar
super chat no question or comment thank
you very much let's jump into the non
super chat comments Evan Holloway says
give me a second I'm becoming a patron
y'all owe me fam twelve people only
twelve away okay let's see what else
we've got I do want to make an effort to
answer non-super chat questions as well
intentions matter when it comes to what
is considered terror I think that is
interesting I mean you can you can argue
that the u.s. in its military strikes
around the world is not taking enough
caution to avoid civilian deaths but the
intention of the u.s. is not to kill
civilians and I do think it's fair to
factor that in to what you considered
and what you don't consider terror I
think that it that that's an absolutely
fair statement to make what else do we
have here anybody else with questions in
the regular chat a lot of just people
chatting amongst themselves which is
great
got to love that appreciate that
somebody's saying that a bird flew into
their window during the livestream that
sounds disturbing all right so not a lot
of not a lot of specific questions for
me in the regular chat and that's that's
perfectly okay we did just inch another
baby step closer to our patreon target
because both Michael Muldoon as well as
Evan Holloway have made pledges and in
fact Michael Muldoon pledged $2 a month
and Evan Holloway pledged $2 a month $2
a month is a popular number when it
comes to pledges and that now gets us
within 10 we're at 1920 we're targeting
1930 and I cannot stay for up for much
longer so I really hope that we can get
just a torrent of these contributions at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
because we I don't want to end the
vacation of the previous and live stream
on a failed patreon pledge but I also
can't stay all night because I've got a
lot of stuff to do a Jacob ball has sent
a 12 dollar and 12 cent super chat make
a Pakman miracle happen let's do it
very few minutes to go and 10 patrons to
go wow wow it would be I feel like it
would be just low energy if we didn't
make it and maybe I set the the the
target too high but I don't think so 15
20 25 patrons during one of these live
streams is pretty common you know I
wonder if I made a strategic mistake
I wonder if because the title of the
live stream is the show is going away
for a while which of course is just
referencing our vacation I wonder if
some people are thinking why would I
make a patreon pledge if the show is
ending or not going to be doing anything
for a while but you would be very very
wrong if that was your understanding
because we've got a whole bunch of great
content that will be published on our
YouTube channel during the
and there will be no shortage of really
really great things for you to check out
on YouTube including for long-form
videos classical liberalism voter fraud
and voter suppression the myth of the
violent left and debunking the talking
point that socialism has never worked so
I would argue that there's actually
going to be a ton of great stuff
did you guys hear that that was was a
very odd noise that was just a ceiling
and it sounded like water was pouring
through the ceiling yeah I'm hearing
that again I really hope that we're not
about to have a caving in of the ceiling
okay we have renewed energy Dana Cooper
has just pledged $1 a month
ciarán Cabezas has pledged two dollars a
month and carry Corollas Burnett has
pledged two dollars a month this has
inched us closer to 1930 we are now at
1923 we are just seven patrons away
seven patrons away from hitting a number
very special number a very important
number which will lead to me publishing
to you a 60% membership discount code
let's do a couple other super chats and
hopefully we can make this happen
Jennifer karein who has previously
sponsored memberships on the David
Pakman show
$20 super chat have you ever had a
member coordinator this would lead to
meetups etc it could be a way to give a
sense of community within the members
and another reason for membership have
an amazing trip back home
that's it that's an interesting question
have we i've thought at some point that
if if the membership program and patreon
get big enough it would make sense to
have someone who manages all that stuff
instead of me and part of it could be
member engagement now the only concern
would be i think if we did meetups
in any particular city we would need to
be open to everybody because if you if
it's only open to members i don't know
that we have enough members in a lot of
cities where if you think well what
percentage of our members are
one city what percentage would be
available on a particular day what
percentage would actually be interested
in going going to one of these meetups I
think we would end up with like two
people if we did member only meetups I
think that the meetup idea is
interesting and there may be something
to that also what about if we were to do
some kind of raffling off of being able
to come into our studio and watch a
taping of the David Pakman show that
could be interesting so I think that
that hmm that could be something but
yeah we would need we would need some
coordination for it no doubt eleven
sleddin has sent a ten dollar super chat
enjoy your vacation make sure to come
back thank you very much I will do my
best to enjoy hopefully there is a
United States to come back to we are
inching yet closer on patreon we're
trying to get to 1930 if we do that will
trigger the biggest membership discount
code I have ever put out there 60% Evan
Bowman has pledged $2 Allen Anderson has
pledged $10 Jordan Barnard has pledged
$1 Mary Jane Fremont has pledged $2
which puts us at 1927 patrons it would
be crazy if I just bailed on the live
stream now right like I plan to do about
an hour but we're only three patrons
away we're three patrons away and it
seems like it would be a huge disservice
to everybody who's waiting for the
biggest discount code ever Patrick carol
has just pledged $2 a month on patreon
Richard a Gil V has pledged $1 a month I
feel like Richard a Gil V has pledged so
many times I don't know how it works
because he must be pledging from
different accounts to keep upping the
number I don't know how it all works but
Richard Richard got it figured out
that's for sure
we are now one patron away from
triggering a 60% discount code alright
that's it for tonight sorry we didn't
make it I'll talk to you guys later just
kidding just kidding
that would be brutal that would be
absolutely brutal if I did that I think
we're gonna get there I think we're
gonna get there we need just one more
patron
I'm so confident it's happening that I'm
gonna start thinking of a clever coupon
code for today we did Kim Jong Donny
last time we've had coupon codes like
cucked no more what would be a funny
theme what would be a funny theme for
the coupon code for today and on that
note thanks to Doug mech Lamont's Orma
Clements $2 a month pledge we are there
we are at 1930 patrons and that means we
are about to get a 60% discount code
what would be a good coupon code though
um what would be a good coupon code I
don't even know anybody want to suggest
something [ __ ] Servet of no I don't
think so nuclear war I'm not sure about
that David brutal brutal Pakman maybe it
should be brutality related I don't know
people asking me by the way what book
I'm reading I do want to address that I
am about to start the sixth extinction
by Elizabeth Kolbert by Elizabeth
Kolbert looking forward to that
fallout 2017 that's interesting Dave by
the way what is an edge Lord somebody
talking about me becoming an edge Lord I
don't even know what that rip is what
that means Trump's hair drums stupid
Watergate I like stupid Watergate that I
really really like that
today's coupon code let me just type it
in and make sure that I don't make a
mistake
stupid Watergate 17 is today's coupon
code okay that will save you 60% off of
membership coupon code I'm pasting it
into the chat window or the description
coupon code stupid Watergate 17 and that
is now up and running it will save you
60% off of membership Richard a Gil V
confirming he uses multiple different
emails and Evan Holloway wanted Trump's
hair as the coupon code but we are going
with stupid Watergate 17 on that note I
bid you good evening and good night if
something major happens I will live
stream during the vacation we've still
got the Friday show tomorrow
and then we are off and then we'll be
back Godspeed
I don't even really know what that means
but I guess what I mean is I hope the
United States is still here when I get
back and Donald Trump hasn't done
anything too stupid